the question is do people go out to
shows if we don't have a vaccine that's
what I'm wrestling with and I don't know
I think so I don't know man
I don't know I hope obviously I mean
that's my livelihood but I don't know if
people will go out to shows because
they've been fed so much information
like hey it's not about you it's about
you know the old lady that lives next to
you or your grandma or all these other
people that are passing because they are
passing they are dying for it and no
from it nobody wants to be responsible
for that death I think honestly once we
have a vaccine everybody gets back to
normal but I think it's gonna be tough
to get back to normal without the
vaccine I mean like here's my I moved my
special taping to November I think we
announced today matter of fact so it's
like I'm hoping by November we can do
that but I'm also hoping by the fall I
can get some reps in last thing I want
to do is go six months without
performing and then tape a special yeah
you know so it's like I I'm more bullish
I think once we have a treatment we
don't need a vaccine once you have a
treatment that's effective enough all
right we're out we're good that's a good
point once you know that your life isn't
on the line yeah
either vaccine or treatment you're ready
to go yeah and what dr. Jimmy's big
balls today from Gotham he did the
hydroxychloroquine he did Clark helped
him saved his life he said who's this
Jimmy big balls remember the security
guy from Gotham oh yeah he thought he
was gonna die man he was on death's
doorstep at the hospital and then they
put chloroquine on him bang two days
later I'm up I'm good again he's got
oxygen up to him but he did our show
this morning and he's feel and he's
preaching by it really yeah and if this
is effective we're back yeah and think
what everybody wants to hate it cuz the
president vouched for it because the
president goes this is a good thing and
everybody's like nah because they hate
the president more than they want to
find a cure it's an interesting dynamic
and I'll watch a little bit of his
[ __ ] and you're like oh he's aware of
some high level conspiracy [ __ ] or he's
just so dumb that he's pretending he is
I tend to believe the latter but I do
think if this Heydrich was a chloroquine
or whatever yeah if that helps dunk we
are this is why I'm bullish on it we are
starved more so for live content than
anything because what's the one thing we
haven't had in the quarantine above all
human interaction you said it I miss
giving people five I miss interacting
with people so if there's entertainment
that is live I want to see that beyond a
[ __ ] TV show or web serie or like
there I've been doing that this whole
time I'm done with that yeah
that's the thing we're always competing
with before is movies oh you're right
dog I trust me I want you to be right
more than anything just my gut it's such
a positive thing he's saying that you
feel it and you feel like it's right
like people are going to be jonesing and
then live stand-up should have I mean we
were booming stand-up was booming it's
gonna if what he says is right it's
gonna hit so much bigger that it's gonna
have this cult thing attached to this
mainstream popularity thing which is
gonna make it you know what they should
do they should just do the temperature
check I'll do a temperature check or do
a UV ray whatever that should I don't
even know they're they've got these
these are these like thermal imaging
things that they put in certain cities
in China you like check people before
you go to the grocery store or any kind
of public event just do that that will
make people feel safe at least so
there's something like you just need
people to feel like they're entering a
secure environment you know if they want
to be they're bad but you need to
present them with some sort of security
I don't know if I said this on the
podcast it's crazy India was so far
ahead of this in early March my
sister-in-law and brother-in-law went
there yeah when they got off the plane
from America they checked every single
person's temperature you know how much
safer you felt about everything and the
flight you just took for everybody
nobody got temperature even if it's
possible to spread it mentally you're
like okay security should be good bro
I'm telling you we want that security
man we don't give a [ __ ] about freedom
brother survival dawg we put everything
but there's a
like when you live in American you grew
up in a time of prosperity you would you
attach yourself to this idea of freedom
that you see his TV shows and movies and
all we care about is rebellion and
freedom all that [ __ ] in the second push
comes the second we got a little
pandemic out there immediately we are so
[ __ ] ready to hand over that freedom
my Hampson protect me crazy man protect
me big government itec me I thought they
were gonna shut down the bridges and the
tunnels a couple weeks ago because when
we left I was like a wonderful at home I
reached out to a cop friend of mine I'm
like you guys shutting down the bridge
and he's like I don't think it'll come
to that but he's like I don't know any
any day you know the new form of being
offended if you go out is someone comes
into your space that's the most
offensive thing that like that's what
you want to fight over now yeah it's
like if someone gets too close to me and
I'll just turn and give him a look like
why is your shopping cart that close to
me don't get that close it's amazing how
this this thing divided a world that was
already so divided it was divided on
class and on race and now it's divided
in terms of physical space you know how
tight that's gonna make people how
increased everything is gonna be like
race relations and [ __ ] with space
because even if it's not racist it's
gonna be rate if you say to someone and
they're a person of color you yes stand
back
well I suppose to me I'm gonna think
it's a race thing Nazi I do understand
what you're saying but I also think that
now there's something bigger than race
that everybody can get on the same page
with also why people never have to worry
about black people not respecting germs
get the [ __ ] away from me white boy but
like they you know how like they won't
pick up after their own dogs because
they think it's dirty there's a yeah you
know you know how like there's certain
things that like supersede your race
right like objectifying a woman right
like there's a girl with a fat ass will
walk down the street and like you look
at the ass and then there's like a
Puerto Rican guy across
Street he looks at the ass man you guys
can kind of like connect over the N
fondant right you had this bonding
moment it was bigger than your racial
division your classes and all these
things right you just grow it is like
you see somebody sneeze and then you can
look at a black dude and black dude
looks at you and you guys just go yo
that was crazy you know and then you can
tap them up afterwards but at least
there's this thing connect with and
that's why I think comedy is gonna be
amazing after this because not only can
you not be offended by the little [ __ ]
anymore like I think the woke stuff is
done but the entire world feels the same
way about the same thing and it's very
rare in history that you get universal
connectivity so when you make a joke
about Corona there's gonna be a lot of
hack [ __ ] but a good bit about Corona is
gonna tap into feelings that everybody
in the audience is gonna have yeah
nobody will have a different feeling
about Corona so it's gonna be a really
cool time for comedy the first maybe six
months that we get out there before
everything becomes hacker this is a
thing that also like big J taught me
years ago where he was like a lot of
people think you can't have one guy do
crowd work that another guy do crowd
work he's like crowd work should always
be different based on who's doing it
right because it brings your own unique
perspective into it so it's like even if
we're all talking about groan of the
first six months which a lot of people
are gonna do my take is gonna be
different than your take my take right
now is like my wife only had three days
worth of clothes so my wife is wearing
her mom's clothes and I'm like damn you
look [ __ ] hot and your mom's gonna
[ __ ] no mom's clothes pajamas and it's
like everyone's perspectives gonna be
different there is gonna be like a lot
of you know what that is I'm trying to
[ __ ] with my mask on you know that I
burn it that's all that stepmom porn
dude mm-hm that's what that is that's
that stepmom form working it into your
psyche my mother-in-law's not like
attractive like that
my jeans just fit my wife better my wife
in los stepmom it's all that [ __ ] that
you've been watching on those websites
and it finally worked itself into your
system inception wise and now you're
dressing your wife up like Nancy doing
her hair with a flow be all short and
spiky and [ __ ] you gotta ask Bob what
she likes where you're dead grandma's
earrings wear the earrings and take your
teeth out
[Applause]